c'est trop tôt quand je la regarde j'ai
je sentais émotion quand on prend trop
grand votre santé en 2012 parce que je
suppose parce que pour cela il faudrait
avoir le même garde de l'enfant que
j'étais devant mon père qui prépare le
début ce soir et toute la subtilité et
l'émotion que mettait cette musique en
moi
venez en faire une entente de la musique
et même parce que je ne voudrais pas
nécessairement les montagnes man cette
musique mais qu'elle avait sur mon père
il était dans un état de bonheur complet
et c'est cette image qui reste dans ton
esprit rebelle écouter autre chose et
les moutons que tout la diva égyptienne
et j'étais même si dans un spectacle je
regardais ma mère chantait avec le divin
il faut dire que ma mère chante très
bien je pense qu'elle chante très bien
parce que nous ferons
j'étais très bien et même mieux que 4e
puisque et l'arménie toujours l'habitude
de précéder aucun tour dans ses chansons
donc les paroles il y avait toujours un
décalage ma mère chantait à maman et
qu'elle tourne la suivait j'avais
toujours l'impression que c'est en
quelques jours qui suivent et ma mère la
membrane inverse et
alors je revienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
ces versions 7 et les placer dans sa
chambre l'entendez c'est un spectacle
encore quand mon père nous pour le maire
je la regardais trémousser danser sur
les rythmes endiablés de cette musique
que je connais les gens christian aussi
parce que nous on est de la même
génération et c'était extraordinaire de
les noter aussi et puis mon frère aussi
partagé dans la musique mais il avait
aussi ses spécificités
puis les flammes que j'aimais aussi
il
alors de cette musique je l'apprécié
mais mon idée il est le cecos you and
very island
mais ce qui me dérange le plus c'était
le look de ces jeunes qui avaient une
influence sur son fils et donc il
voulait absolument comment vous son fils
concret ne se vide pas la même coiffure
maintenant vous vous demandez et moi
qu'est ce que j'entendais comme musique
alors j'ai goûté le sang mais surtout je
ramenais un petit peu notre musique du
visible
rama est la cible le thème plus une
musique engagée de chanteur palestinien
de chanteurs libanais mais surtout
surtout une musique francophone
parce qu'il est gentil était le fruit et
maintenant je suis en train de me
contrôler je ne peux pas nier nos
querelles dans ses chansons ce qui me
manque c'est plus nous étions une petite
famille dans un espace assez élevé mais
que nous avions chacun sa musique
préférée
et pourtant tous ces disques là dans cet
espace très restreint ne se traduise pas
par du bruit ou par une dissonance et y
installe deux raisons la première c'est
que chacun aimait sa musique et n'avait
aucune envie peut-être aucune volonté
mont-bleu de la nausée aux autres ce qui
fait plus en terre et goûter appelle
l'aide mais trouver tout à fait normal
que nous les mettions et donc vous ne
posez pas ça et donc on n'était pas dans
une sorte de prosélytisme
physiquement on est mort son ca c'est la
première règle enfin la première raison
la deuxième c'est que nos avions savions
comment envisager cette pluralité
musicalement d'abord pour mes parents
c'était le respect et donc comment faire
l'été sa musique de ma mère mettait en
musique ont gardé le silence
on mettait pas d'un autre et pour tous
les jeunes quant à se rebeller n'utilise
montrèrent savait pertinemment que s'il
mettait un peu plus fort la sq ni moi ni
ma soeur mettra un peu plus fort bitches
il remettra un peu plus forts de ce
rival et dans ceux qui créent château de
volume qui remonte personne de finir à
vendre et donc on avait compris que si
on voulait entendre tous les deux quand
il ya le bac il fallait au contraire
baisser le son et n'ont pas augmenté le
sang alors c'est comme ça que mentir
cette pluralité et moi je me pose une
question concernant un orchestre
philharmonique simplement un orchestre
philharmonique ont fait pas toujours
attention à cela
mais moi j'ai trouvé bizarre le nombre
de vues
triste je vous dis vous êtes dans une
école de gestion
je quittais trois satellites et autres
hauts salaires de moins pourquoi est ce
que c'est à part ça je vous pose la
question comment des instruments aussi
variés et aussi éloignés les uns des
autres peuvent coexister pour une grosse
qu'un seul à se montrer ou confirmer ma
camionnette
je pense que mclaren avait perdu 6 2
violons se mettaient à lutter contre la
dame anne je pense qu'elle perdra ont
réussi ce mélange cette complexité
ramène quelque chose dans mon mieux
c'est parce que j'avais largement ses
amis chaque instrument apporte quelque
chose et ont l'intelligence aller contre
instruments et si je vous parle de tout
cela c'est pour venir un petit d'abord à
la notion de la pluralité et la
complexité des choses c'est internet
dans un musée
quand j'ai vu ça j'ai aussi dit je
pourrais le faire aussi émettre un
tableau comme ça dans un musée et il est
certain qu'on n'aurait pas accepté parce
que ce tableau très sombre affaire est
intéressant que parce qu'il a un effet
par un artiste qui a montré par ailleurs
qu'il est capable de faire de la
bouillie complexe et donc tout l'intérêt
ici ce qu'il a un peu transgressives
rennes mais autrement je pense que
personne ne remettra ce tome nous parce
qu il vous suffit d'acheter une toile du
peintre que vous voulez vous pouvez dire
de ces applications si vous voulez donc
la mandature
quand ma musique c'est une question de
pluralité et mieux piloter ma muse j'en
viens à la question
parce que nous sommes dans un pays
officiellement mis la main et la
question des langues
pourquoi posant toujours la question en
termes de confinement nature de ma mère
quelqu'un a dit quelque part que les
êtres humains communiquer mieux sont les
mieux avant de cliquer pluralité dès
lors imaginer qu'il y avait une époque
un paradis où les gens le par les knicks
membres et créé de gros titres on pense
que palais présidentiel et non plus par
les seuls occidentaux en général et pour
la nouvelle carte colorier qui seraient
10 points de vues de la tour de babel
l'offre erp incarner parce que là vous
avez de chaque couleur une langue aucun
débit ne s'est mis à part peut-être une
petite île qu'on ne sait plus dans une
longue rangée dans ses frontières
politiques soit la banque démente
soyez mesures banques dans le même pays
et en politique alors ça devrait être
des gens qui ne s'entendent pas c'est
quand même les spas saunas troisième
économie mondiale
c'est quand même un espace qui quand de
tous les maux de vue économique culturel
ou historique d'où ce que vous voulez
cdi lens si différents ont réussi avec
le rni klout ils sont tous mes pantalons
plusieurs langues le nombre c'est dans
cette langue
28 je suppose au parce que l'angleterre
en se retirant il ya un document clé et
bien non et s'ils vont descendre un peu
le mans plus bas dans la méditerranée m
voilà nous avons cet espace
c'était ça s'appelle le monde arabe
alors il s'appelle du monde arabe et je
pense que mara mais si beaucoup plus la
langue que l'ennemi pas parce que les p
-o si vous passez dépassé j'ai s'est
passé
l'arabie saoudite je pense que tous les
autres sont mélangés dos et sur la base
de la langue on regarde et on croit cet
espace comme étant l'année sera sans
gêne qu'il parle officiellement ont rien
dit et c'est comme ça qu'on le voit
moins mais si vous faites l'analyse il
n'a probablement aucun pays qui n'est
pas en conflit avec l'entreprise
et si vous voyez du produit économique
puisque vous êtes en congé d'école
d'économie les échanges entre ces pays
dans le monde anecdotique quand on
mesure avec les échanges avec l'europe
par exemple mais ça cesser l'indivision
tout simplement parce que la vérité et
je ne prends que d'un magasin c'est
certain ça ces derniers temps je ne
prends pas les autres langues
je ne parle pas de la magie et le
parlement du cur le corps etc
je parle peu des diana ce qui fait que
mon talent inné c'est un peu court a
tenu compte de la vision commun c'est
c'est un manque une jeune
une unité qui est un peu fantasmé
héros malheureux parce que pensent les
européens sommes différents et ils vont
vers l'unité
nous pensons que nous avons perdu mais
dd on arrive à faire que de revenir à
l'unité qui m'a jamais existé en réalité
donc si vous pouvez accepter ses
diversités
on pourrait au sein de cette diversité à
l'aîné depuis un peu à l'image de ma
famille à vimont pour le moment le des
mamans linguistique est un débat houleux
on se pose des questions quel est le
nombre nationale quelle raison de
l'identité créneau officiel qu'elle une
amende de renseignement dernièrement la
poser ses questions et jacques roy la
question est posée en termes de quelle
la norme qu'on doit exclure et mon
paquet d'éléments qu'on doit prendre
voir et donc dans cette logique de
l'exclusion
si je reviens marie c'est comme s'ils
peuvent en écoutant benetti disait
panneaux trois députés d'autres plus
qu'une passion ce n'est pas notre
identité nos centres d'asile
on a pas mal écouté les chansons avant
mes chansons françaises ou anglaises et
vous en conviendrez avec moi je pense
qu'à ça je vous remercie